so straight away once the the body's
been embalmed sometimes they're not but
if they're being viewed they they will
be embed um so what it does it um you
take the blood out of one and then the
you know EMB Bing fluid goes in so it
preserves the body and it can preserve
the body for a long long time once it's
in the fridge um so once that is all
done then it's my job then to come in
and and I I will dress and I will do the
hair makeup I've dyed hair before I've
done spray tans I paint their nails um
anything that needs to be done I would
do then dress them and then um I usually
wait and wait for them to go into the
coffin or their casket rearrange and
then then then then they're ready for
viewing with the family